okay we're doing your chat
okay you ready to go
james yes we are yeah thank you very
much okay
thank you well welcome everyone to
today's meeting of the joint
transportation board
both those that are participating and
those who are watching from home
if you have technical difficulties
during the meeting please contact the
democratic service officer and call
who will attempt to assist you today's
officer on call is katie and the number
to call is one eight four three
five seven seven zero four six
i would ask participants when you're not
speaking to mute your microphone this
minimizes background noise
and will help everyone hearing the
proceedings microphones must only be on
if the participant has been granted
permission to speak
to gain permission to speak please
indicate in the chat to the right side
of the screen
now would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they're not used to make
or receive phone calls whilst
meeting is in progress please also
refrain from checking emails or
conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed to members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will be subsequently brought to
broadcast on the internet please can i
ask members of the board and officers to
confirm their present in the meeting
when i read out your name
so i believe uh council christendom will
not be here but
uh councillor christendom
no council of fellows
yeah evening chair evening councillor
heart
oh here chad councillor keane
here chair thank you councillor may
saunders
chairman
yes here chair councillor lewis
and not here and councillor messenger
nope
okay and officers um are
uh mr valach mr flattson
evening chair evening
evening mr speakers mr thomas
evening chair and miss shuttleworth
evening chair good evening everyone uh
are there any non board members who wish
to speak under council procedure rule 21
not i'm aware of chad thank you so we're
going to agenda item one which is
apologies for absence
uh i believe apologies we'll receive
from tower councillor pennington
and council crittenden are there any
other apologies for abstinence
councillor dawson has also often
apologized
okay thank you very much
no others agenda item two is
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
there might be um because i think
parking might be discussed and we own a
shop in birchington that's liz
elizabeth yeah i did raise an email
sorry about this well i've got barking
dogs in the background
um
get down chef okay
um i'm not quite sure okay that's if the
parking is introduced okay thank you
very much any other interests
no we've gone to agenda item three which
is minutes of the previous meeting
which you will have received
do members agree that the minutes of the
joint transportation board meeting held
on the 15th of december
2020 be approved as a correct record
can i have can i have a proposal please
councillor may saunders and a seconder
councillor david hart and
i heard a lot of agrees so i'm taking it
that everyone's happy with that
thank you agenda item for sonic highways
works program 2020 to 20
20 20 to 2021. i call upon mr valeck
from uh fanny district manager kcc to
present the report
thank you chair good evening everybody
um uh as uh most of you are aware the
highway x programme
um we're at the end of uh this year and
the high works program gives detail for
schemes approved for this year
as we are at the end of the year much of
what is on the highway works program is
showing a completed status and uh by the
time we get round to the next jtb we'll
have a
much fuller um program
i'm not minded to go through every every
bit of detail as usual but i will we'll
go through
um the the appendixes
and pick out uh some of the more
significant schemes i'm starting with
appendix a
the road and footwear cycle renewal and
preservation
scheme uh as you've probably seen site
of the report most of everything is
completed on there we have
one site cliff terrace from zion place
to athenston road that's to be
investigated for 2021
a couple of uh schemes um at the at the
bottom
uh sorry at the top uh hank um
canterbury road west from hengist way to
hame road
that's to be programmed and the b2050
manston road uh which is the section of
manston road that runs from the old
airport terminal where
where the test center is now through to
the spitfire crossroads you've probably
seen that that's
in a pretty poor condition and we're
waiting for that to be
programmed for repair
going down through um footwear footwear
schemes for this year
one one that's been confirmed as i say
as we get into next year there'll be
more confirmed but one that's been
confirmed is new cross street in margate
there's a section of footwear in new
cross street margate where there are a
lot of
private sellers where the footwear is in
a poor condition where we're looking to
do
some strengthening works and renewal to
the footway there
appendix b drainage schemes uh george
fifth avenue
uh the main scheme there that's that's
the work's complete and the planting has
now gone in place and hopefully we
should start seeing that looking nice
once the spring
comes and things start to get a bit
greener
the next scheme that we're looking at is
hearts down road
uh where it floods at the bottom near
the
cricket pitch and that's added to the
forward work work
program for replacement soak aways
appendix c as usual lists the sites that
have
the street lights that have been
identified as part of the structural
testing regime
for replacement
um appendix d transportation schemes the
main
the main one of interest there um for
now is the new crossing
at um canterbury road outside ursuline
school
ursuline college that's a local
transport plan
scheme um there's no externally funded
schemes at present
no local growth fund schemes at present
and there's a long list of
developer-funded works
um one of the significant ones which you
will have seen that's just
opened now on the 278 agreement
is nash road the new section of road
that is 278 money as part of the housing
development up there
um scrolling down i'll take i will take
questions obviously at the end as well
bridge works there have been some
upgrades to the safety of barriers on
the thanet way
and uh the bridge at moncton
where we've currently got traffic lights
on because there's a weight restriction
on it
uh due to it due to it being weak the
traffic lights
will be removed soon and some priority
signage to be installed
and some bridge the bridge refurbishment
design has commenced
no works on public right right subway um
appendix h
traffic systems uh
there there's one one site that's
completed which is mill mid road
at the junction median valley road and
then there are four sites proposed
it says here for february february
february 21 at the time of writing
which are upgrading to an existing
crossing at westwood road
high street and carlton avenue
broadstairs i know that's that's been
completed
here's some road near montefiore avenue
and high street near prospect place
broadstairs
combine member grant schemes these are
the schemes that have been
approved for funding with the relevant
officer and simon jones director of
highways
and they include the contribution um to
the puffing crossing outside earthline
from emma dawson and uh liz hurst
and um canterbury and then another
scheme canterbury road birchington and
park lane birchington the installation
of two small
uh four four small mammal signs two on
each road
uh that i can confirm that those works
are complete as well
appendix j lists the um
road closures in the area that are
planned that
are in excess of 10 days
a fair list there as you as you would
have seen
and that completes the highway works
program thank you
thank you chair thank you paul um do
members have any questions on these
um or any questions regarding highways
works generally on street
councilor hurst and the only thing i was
going to
the only thing i was going to highlight
um
with street lighting is that there is
one ongoing for instance in westgate in
elm grove which
um i have passed on to highways but
it's been raised to me because of the
current
um police investigation that is ongoing
um london sandwich
and i've got an inkling that this is
going to perhaps become a little bit
more
highlighted to us i'm being quite sort
of diplomatic here
um because of people being concerned
that streets aren't necessarily
necessarily bright enough for ladies to
be walking about of the night um
elm grove in westgate i don't know
personally i haven't been there of an
evening
but apparently it's quite a sort of dull
lighting
but it is something perhaps to bear in
mind because i think we might get more
of these
raised in future and that's all i was
really going to say on this
um just highlighting that i think we
might get more because of the current
issue anyway thank you thank you
do members of any other members have a
comment can i
ask a question please uh council fellow
yeah question sir uh mr valley uh at the
top of um
part lane in birchington as you get
towards quakes we used to have an
illuminated
30 mile an hour time which has
disappeared and that's never been
replaced can you
tell me if it's going to be replaced
because this definitely still needs some
work at the brunswick junction
to slow traffic down that's heading into
the village
yeah thank you thank you council fellows
um
you're right there was one there and uh
it was it was hit i believe
uh in an rtc um our
traffic systems manager toby butler has
um
has responded um and given a response on
on that and
um no it's not going back um i i can
find that response which is obviously a
fuller response than i'm able to give
you now
and maybe get that get that across you
would that help yeah i mean i
i get occasionally people writing to me
saying you know is there anything that
can be done
at that junction to slow the traffic
down on that bend which is
it is bad i mean if you live in
purchasing or you travel around bursting
you know that that is initially there
yeah sorry to interrupt you yeah i i i
um
obviously over the years we've done a
lot of work at that junction
um we've been you know um lining
some signing we moved the um the 30 mile
per hour
limit uh uh border if you like from
the village side of kwek's entrance to
the
um a coal side of quek's entrance and
yes i mean
you know i live in bucharest and i'm
familiar with the area but um
and there's you know 30 mile per hour
signs as you enter the area
but it doesn't matter seem to matter
what we do
you can sit at brunswick junction want
to come out and turn right
and there there will always be the odd
one that come around that corner
going faster than they should and they
did that even even with the interactive
sign there
um but um um yeah i'm not sure that
there's anything more we can do there
but um
with regard to the response for the
interactive sign
going and not going back let me speak to
toby butler
um and see if i can get a more fuller
response than i'm able to give you
tonight
i believe one went went out some time
ago did
was it right did you raise it um um liz
hurst
yeah i did actually i raised exactly and
in fact somebody spoke to me today about
the same
issue um and i did explain that as far
as i knew that sign wasn't going back up
again
but yeah it's a big issue in birchington
as council fellows said
and it is a very dangerous road in fact
one of the residents raised it to me who
lives very close to it
today and i said you know i'm really
sorry but i don't think that sign's
going back
up um i think it does need looking into
further
but short of slowing drivers down which
as you said they don't all do
i don't know what the answer is either
but it definitely
needs to be continually looking that
looked at
thank you
thank you chair um my only uh issue with
that
is that is it no way we could put a
mirror opposite so that
traffic coming out of brunswick can look
in a mirror and see what is coming from
the
from their right um you know a lot of
houses have these stuck across the road
don't they so they can look out left and
right so you can see
past vegetation because not everybody
has a 175
foot visibility line is there anything
we can do with that put a
you know either a mirror or a camera or
something there that just shows what's
coming around the corner
there there is a a very um strict
process
um for mirrors on the highway and uh i'm
not able to quote all of the detail now
but
um they they they
do have their place um i i don't believe
that there are many places
that that there are for them that like i
say the process is strict
they can um lead to a false sense of
security to users they can become
misted up dirty they're not the best in
in in bad weather
um so they they they do have their
faults
but um i i take i'll take your point but
there is a there is a policy and process
for it
um and i'm not sure that one one would
be
um permitted there but maybe something
to look into
can i ask a question please okay thank
you
um given that the sign was lost because
there was an accident there do we have
any stats on
numbers of accidents there
um to hand i don't i mean obviously the
crash data history for any location is
available to everybody online now
um and there's there's a there's a link
there's a link
through um the kcc website highways
website
um that that takes it takes you uh
through to uh this site where you can
get your own crash data
okay thank you any other questions
um i will ask one and that is that it's
been commented to me that um
of why uh traffic lights were actually
being um uh
replaced when they were working and i
just wondered is it a standard that they
have
20 years or whatever it is and then they
have to be replaced
because um in broad stairs the ones that
have just been done the high street
were working um i don't know if you can
answer that to talk paul
uh yeah apologies i'm not able to answer
that question tonight uh but i i
i'll go away to toby butler and get a
good answer as to
i should imagine it's probably um it
might be life span it might be software
uh something like that but i'll ask i'll
ask toby about that i just wondered if
you know because uh obviously if they're
still working they're lasting longer
than maybe the lifespan that's been
assessed for them
yeah and of course people were saying
well why are you replacing when it's
already
working um
if if i could if so just on the few
questions that i've had tonight if i can
just say
that the the question from yourself
chair regarding the lights i'll take
away and come back to you on that
and then the same about the junction um
uh with
um brunswick and park lane that i'll
come back to councillor fellas and liz
hurst on that okay
okay thank you thank you very much
uh were there any other questions that
members wanted to bring up
regarding this or other issues i
appreciate that it's not on the agenda
but
i think this is the opportunity if
people wish to bring something up
uh and discuss it that we do so council
heart
one second then we'll um call an end to
the
um the live feed and the meeting
yeah and then we can have a more general
discussion about
other things that aren't on the agenda
and and with the officers that are here
that's yeah okay okay i'll just ask
katie to um to stop the
recording and we can